In today's Business English episode we’re
talking about the art of negotiation.
Now, negotiating looks
different in different cultures.
But, today we’re going to
look at the first two steps
and language must-haves to negotiate
within a British cultural context.
So, to start off with, you
have to take step number 1:
Learn the gentle art of small talk.
Don’t get down to business straight away.
Morning, morning, so I’ll give
you £200 for 10 garden gomes.
That approach is just going to frighten people,
and make everyone feel uncomfortable.
Rather, you need to break the ice.
Hi, lovely day today isn’t it?
I thought it was going to rain.
I know, we should conduct this meeting
outside, although apparently it’s not
going to last. My app says it’s going
to rain in 10 minutes and 20 seconds.
Or
Hi
Hello, welcome! Before we start,
would you like a cup of tea and some cake?
Yes please, oh my goodness, you’ve read my mind!
This cake is just amazing, did
you, did you make it this morning?
Oh that’s very kind of you, no, no, no, it’s just
Marks and Spencers, but they’re good aren’t they?
The best small talk is on topics that aren’t
controversial. Never talk about things
that people feel too emotional about,
for example, politics, finances,
whether you love or hate Marmite.
The best and most comfortable small talk
is when you talk about everyday things.
Food, travel, the weather.
Once you’ve covered the appropriate subjects for
small talk, you need to take step number two:
Open negotiations reluctantly.
I’m sorry, you’re not there to negotiate, they're
not there to negotiate, who’s here to negotiate?
You all are.
After 10 minutes of tea, cake, talking about
whether you should bring your umbrella to work
tomorrow, you can shift into the,
'let’s get down to business' gear.
Do me a favour, take a pen and paper
and write down these sentences.
'I suppose we’d better get
started. Does anyone mind?'
'If no one objects, shall we
take a look at the agenda?'
'Would anyone like more tea
before we get cracking?'
Remember, you need to make it sound
like you’re having such a good time
and the last thing you want
to do is start negotiations.
Cue step number three:
Make your proposal.
But I won’t talk about it in this video.
If you want to read about the 6 language
must-haves to negotiate in English,
read the blog linked to above.
You’ll be selling gnomes in no time!
We have so much Business English
language knowledge and skills that
we want to share with you so make
sure you subscribe to this channel,
because a lot more videos are going
to be coming your way very soon.
If you want to improve your
business English language skills,
click on the link in the description and it will
take you to the English Online website where you
can have a look at our courses that are designed
to specifically help you with Business English.
To read the full blog, the link is also in
the description. See you next time, bye!